here's the video explaining what's wrong
with the two envelope fallacy I read a
lot of different solutions from you guys
but this is the one that's most
satisfying for me now again we have two
envelopes and for concreteness we'll say
one has $1 and the other two I pick an
envelope but I don't open it now
remember the fallacy went like this my
envelope has some unknown amount X but
the other envelope has either 2 X or 1/2
X each with an equal probability
so in expectation the other envelope has
X plus 1/4 X in it which is more than X
and so I should swap now here's my
solution let's think of it in terms of
actual money assigned and then it will
be super obvious what's wrong say that
unknown to me my envelope contains $1
and so X is $1 then what does the other
contain it's 2 right
but my previous calculation was trying
to say it's either half $1 or $2 and
similarly if my ex had been actually $2
then the other is $1 and never $4 so
claiming that the other envelope
contains either 2x or 1/2 X is wrong
what that's saying is regardless of X
this is true about the other envelopes
value but what we can see from the two
cases is this is clearly not true for
any value of X how do you do this
correctly then you don't know which of
the two cases you're actually in and so
what you should do is average over the
amount in the other envelope in each of
those cases that gives you a value of
1.5 for the expectation value halfway
between the two possible values more
formally the expectation value of the
second envelope is the probability that
your X is 1 times the amount in the
other envelope if that is the case plus
the probability your X is 2 times the
amount in the other envelope if that's
the case since the expectation value is
exactly what you'd expect now you
shouldn't bother swapping
thank you for all your comments about
this fallacy lots of you saw what the
problem was
but what I also really really liked is
that even when many of you couldn't
figure it out you still commented with
some ideas you had about it and some
hunches that's the point of all these
puzzle videos I make it's to get you
thinking whether you get the answer or
not is irrelevant